i'm here i'm here
just a second
all right so uh this is your applause
thank you very much
beautiful talk very nice questions
so it gives me really great uh great
pleasure to
introduce netsmea uh reason is because i
just today when when we were chatting
before
i recall that i know we know each
other's already for
around 10 years and at that time netsme
was
a postdoc at caltech but in the
meanwhile
she became uh very famous and did lots
of work
in a control theory service just
checking her website and it's really
impressive the list of awards that she
got for her research
she got uh nsf career award darpa young
faculty award
nasa early career award derpa director's
fellowship and i could just go on
this way i would probably take all her
time
so uh she's really doing great and
she's now associate professor at uh
university of michigan and thank you
very much uh uh nesme that you agreed to
give a talk at this
seminar so the floor is yours
sorry i'm muted uh thank you so much for
zina and
the others for uh inviting me uh
and uh for organizing this event
so i am going to talk about uh our work
on
coordination of large collections of
dynamical systems
with some constraints expecting
guarantees
and this is joint work with two of my
former students
peter nelson and yunus jahin and
my current students and collaborator
johanna mathieu she is working on
smart grids and power systems so
she motivated this research and she's
still pushing us
to solve more realistic problems in more
realistic settings
so i will just get in the problem
directly so if you are solving a
synthesis problem
you have two components that goes into
your synthesis engine
uh what is your one is your system model
and the other one is
your specification and most of this
work most of this talk will focus on the
model part
and i will ask how we can scale this
model to be
fairly complex or large scale in a
certain sense
and still synthesize and give guarantees
and at the end i will also mention
a new class of specifications that we
came up with
uh using the type of systems we were
looking into
in this work so the system models i will
be looking at
would be uh differential equations so
this is the most
general form of uh the model that
i will present but then i will
specialize and i will show you
the specific structure that arises in
many different contexts that we will use
so there's some state space here you
either have a continuous time
differential equation or discrete time
difference equation
you have some states x you have some
continuous control inputs
continuous meaning these input
set is in iran you have some discrete
control inputs you have
finitely many choices this also
appear a lot in cyber physical systems
if you have switches
or valves those type of components
you have disturbances both discrete and
continuous
continuous disturbances are something we
are very familiar in control
so these are things that directly
affecting your dynamics
and discrete disturbances you can think
about it
as failures or some outside
signals you should respond things like
maybe a traffic signal that you are
responding to
and in most of the uh problems
in real world we have hard constraints
both on the inputs and states
we have infinite horizon specifications
so
typically in control we look into
stability type things where we care
about what happens in the limit
but here we will be looking at all
transients and
infinite horizon properties so there is
this
hybridness both in the system uh and in
the controller so there are
many cases even if you don't have
hybridness in your system
to satisfy complex specifications you
might need hybrid controllers and you
need this robustness
that paulo uh very well motivated i
guess
and the focus of this talk would be
what can we do when the state space
is are in our end a subset of rn
and n is very large is there a class of
systems and some structure that we can
utilize so that we can solve synthesis
problems where
n is very large
so there are many methods out there for
cps control synthesis
and scalability is a big bottleneck that
we have been attacking from different
directions and there are many factors
that affects the
scalability so state space dimension is
fun
but there's complexity of dynamics
complexity of specifications
and the types of results you might want
to get from this process
and again in this talk i will try to
address
scalability from the perspective of uh
state space demands
so there is quite a bit of work i am
seeing state of the art
here but most of the references that i
am gonna give they are gonna be like
four or five years old so we are doing
much better these days
uh but we know how to solve synthesis
problems for
hard state input constraints hybrid
dynamics complex specifications using
temporal logic for small scale systems
so
there are applications where you are
trying to control an individual robot
or a couple of rooms in a building or
you are
trying to control an individual vehicle
or
certain subsystems of an aircraft or
more complex system but these are
usually
small state spaces in small system
scale problems and here are some results
from the literature that tries to apply
uh synthesis type ideas for cyber
physical systems and depending on the
specification complexity
uh the dimension of the state space you
can handle
is roughly like this so if you have very
simple safety type specifications maybe
you can do
15 20 dimensional systems now these
numbers are a little better as i said
uh this is a bit uh dated
and if you keep increasing the
complexity of the specification the
system dimensions that you can handle uh
drops a little bit and there are tools
out there
for uh solving these problems as well
so there are also medium scale systems
that people develop synthesis methods
for and they use
some properties of the system dynamics
to develop such metal methods so what
are those
properties so monotonicity is one of the
properties that
that was shown to be useful in the
setting
using some multi-scale abstractions and
hierarchies
and composition were shown to be useful
if you use these type of tricks maybe
these are tricks
standard and some of them are trig
standard in computer science if you
bring in these type of tricks of
compositionality and such
then you can scale a little bit up
and there is also large-scale
systems there is work on large-scale
systems
where you do uh parametric verification
of hybrid automator
abstraction of large scale of st large
scale stochastic systems but these works
they don't do synthesis but they look at
abstractions or verifications
those type of properties but there's a
recurring
theme here uh if you start scaling up
uh you are utilizing structural
properties and we want to see
if there are other structural properties
we can utilize to make
this synthesis process much more
scalable
and i started to talk with this large
collections of systems and i will give
two motivating examples
one is emergency response with a robot
smart swarm
so there's an emergency an earthquake
you want to deploy a large collection of
robots
there could be quadrotors there could be
ground vehicles and you want to do some
search and rescue mission
and you want to plan trajectories for
individual robots
in a dynamically consistent way and you
have different types of
requirements maybe you want sufficiently
many robots in different
areas and maybe you want not too many
robots in certain regions if there's a
bridge that's about to collapse you
don't want to send too many robots there
then there are this individual collision
avoidance
or charging reporting type constraints
for individual robots
let me show you another example in a
very different
class of systems this is a problem in
a smart grid this is the coordination of
thermostatically controlled loads
if you are not familiar with what
thermostatically controlled loads are
these are
fridges water heaters
air conditioners that has a thermostat
in it
and that turns on and off and it has
been shown
that you can use these devices and
change their due to cycle a little bit
and if you use these devices in a large
number in a neighborhood
and you start changing their duty cycle
these can be used to help demand
response so
they can be used as storage devices if
you have
renewable energy coming in you can store
energy in these devices
uh and you can use that and add when you
are
licking your
renewable generation again there are
certain requirements for
these devices you don't want to turn on
too many of them at the same time you
don't want these devices
to synchronize because then you will be
extracting
too much power from the grid and that's
dangerous for
overloading the grid and you want to
have sufficiently many of them
to be on especially if you have some
renewable generation
and you want to use these as storage
devices
and there are local temperature
constraints you don't want to do it
by violating people's comfort
constraints or by
spoiling their food in their fridge
so what are the common structural
properties between
these two different looking examples
the first properties there's a large
number of systems
but small number of classes you don't
have zillions of different quadrotors so
you maybe have
hundreds of a certain type uh
hundreds of sorts and other types
similarly air conditioners and fridges
they are very similar and you have this
large number
within each class then the constraints
and requirements are related to
how many of them are in a certain mode
or how many of them
are in what region so there's this
similarity in the requirements as well
and one other thing that's important
here is that identity of the individual
systems is not important
in satisfying these type of requirements
so if you have a search and rescue
mission you don't really care
if quadrotor number one goes and rescues
person number one
or quadrotor number 10 goes and rescues
that person so there's that
uh
symmetry type property there as well and
for simplicity i only assume dynamics
are identical for each class and there
is
only one class and i will show how to
relax them
later so let's try to mathematically
formulate our problem
uh let's look at maybe air conditioner
and the temperature of the air
conditioner evolves
with respect to these dynamics if the
air conditioner is on
you have certain uh dynamic evolution
and if it's off
you have certain dynamic evolution
evolution and you are controlling this
on off uh level you are trying to figure
out when to turn on
branch turn off we have a collection of
these air conditioners in a neighborhood
or in a cd
so we have a large number and of these
air conditioners that we can control
from the customers perspective there is
a desired temperature that they want to
achieve in their uh
room so you only allow small deviations
from that desired temperature
so there's this local constraint from
the customer's perspective
and there's a global constraint from the
utility companies or power companies
perspective
where you don't want to turn on too many
of these devices
at the same time time and i am
indicating that with this indicator
function
of uh which of these devices are on
and i want the sum of the devices that
are on simultaneously
to be bounded so that i can control the
power consumption of these devices
i can generalize this so i have a switch
system i am controlling these switches
there are m different modes and i have
an
identical devices of this form there are
local constraints
where i want these
states to be in certain sets locally
and i want to have the number of systems
in a certain mode
in the power case number of systems
extracting power from the grid
to be bounded and i can have different
bonds for
different such modes so
and the structural property if you look
at this problem is that
both dynamics and specifications
uh have this permutation in variance so
i can just swept the location of my
states
and i swept the location of my
specifications and i will get the exact
same formula and we want to use this
permutation in variance to
develop a scalable method for solving
these type of problems
so here is how we develop a solution for
this problem the first thing we will do
is we will construct a symbolic
abstraction
uh then for an individual device
and we will try to aggregate them to
define an equivalent problem
then i will show you some properties of
this uh
aggregation and abstraction uh process
and that will reveal some fundamental
limitations then we will develop an
optimization based approach
for solving the problem in this
aggregate model
so what is the symbolic model if you
have a
non-linear system or any dynamical
system
you can construct a graph structure that
captures certain properties of the
system
and for this we use some methods
developed by
paulo earlier and essentially what we
will do is
since i am controlling the switches for
each switching mode
this is my phase portrait i will
grid up my space state space
and from each point in discrete in this
gridded space
i will simulate my dynamics for
a time discretization i will fix time
discretization as well
i will simulate my state for delta units
of time
and i will look at where the simulation
ends up
and i will just connect the two points
in a graph if this simulation ends up
closest to this other point
and i will do it for different dynamics
and i will in the end
construct a graph using these individual
simulations
from gridded points and if you do your
time to
discretization and state discretization
carefully
one thing you can show is that for every
walk
on this finite graph which you can
imagine jumping over
these points there exists a continuous
trajectory of the system
whose time and state discretized version
or who is time discretized version will
be epsilon close
to this work that jumps on grid points
and similarly for every trajectory of
the system
there is going to be a corresponding
walk on this graph
and that time discretized version of
this trajectory will remain epsilon
close
to the wall here if you interpret the
valk as jumping over
these grid points and to achieve that
type of
uh by simulation we use this uh
incremental stability property of the
dynamics
and you can show that uh there is a
smart way of
choosing your state discretization and
time discretization
uh such that you can guarantee that you
can achieve this epsilon closeness
uh as long as you do your state
discretization and time discretization
properly
but we are doing it for an individual
device and we have
maybe thousands of these devices so how
do i go from
this graph structure that represents an
individual device
to a graph structure that represents
thousands of devices so
traditionally you can take these graphs
and take
you can imagine these are automata and
you can try to construct a product
automaton
but we don't want to do that because n
is large and my product automaton will
be large
so what i will do instead is
i will treat this graph
as a histogram because
all of my systems have identical graphs
and if i treat this as a histogram and
if i have
10 systems whose states are closer to
this
upper left dot i will just put a 10
over here in this node of this graph in
the v0 node
and at each time i can take a snapshot
of
where my dynamics are and from that
snapchat
looking at where each stator i can form
a histogram uh on my graph by assigning
numbers
on these nodes of this graph that i
construct
and it turns out that depending on how
you turn on and off
these systems you can write the dynamics
of this histogram
and this is uh what i am gonna do next
but before that uh i want to
i forget i hit the slide i want to
mention a few relaxations there
so if you construct this graph in the
way that i described
this graph is deterministic so from
action deterministic
in the sense that from each node with
the same action you go to a single
uh other node but you can also relax
this and we assume that everything is
identical so far
you can also relax this to mild
heterogeneity
and if you have some disturbances or
parameter differences between
uh different systems there is still a
smart
state discretization and time
discretization it's a little more
constrained that will give you these
type of graphs so you can
if you discretize your state and time
carefully uh all stable systems look
alike so that's the
high level idea so if you have stable
systems you can find these
discretizations in state and time
that will give you identical graphs and
once you have the identical graphs as i
said
you can treat this graph as a histogram
and you can now look at how these
numbers on the histogram evolve
and to define that i will define a
different type of state
that essentially counts the number of
systems
in a given mode it's a given
node of this graph and i will call it w
and i will define my inputs as
the number of systems at a given
node of this graph that switch from mode
one
to mode two and with these state and
input definitions then i can write the
dynamics of
this histogram how this histogram
evolves as i switch my systems
from on and off and it turns out that
these dynamics of the histogram is a
linear system
it's a linear system evolving on an
integer
letters with some constraints on the
inputs and this input constraints
essentially says
if i don't have any system at a mode at
a given
node i cannot switch them
so there's a lower bound on what i can
switch that's my
input constraint and there's an upper
bound if there's n
systems in a given node then i can add
more switch and systems
at a given time so the dynamics on the
histogram
is a linear system on an integer lattice
with input constraints
then uh i can state this theorem uh
if my original problem
has a solution original synthesis
problem has a solution
then there exists a solution to this
linear problem
where you have some input constraints
and your counting constraints ends up
being linear constraints in this
new domain as well next quick quick
question
what do you mean by the original problem
the one before we did the epsilon uh b
simulation or the uh
after we did before the epsilon
simulation the switch
continuous time uh
switch system problem where we are
designing these switches
for individual systems and if that
problem has a solution
then this problem has a solution up to
an excellent accuracy and if this
problem is okay all right thanks
okay so essentially these are up to this
epsilon
accuracy if you just that epsilon
accuracy affects how you
shrink or uh expand your safety
constraints
these two problems are equivalent that
if i want to solve my initial switch
scheduling problem
i can go and solve a linear problem and
the nice thing about this linear problem
is that
the state dimension here does not depend
on the number of devices that i have
it only depends on the size of the graph
that i have so this is really giving us
a problem that's
dimension independent if the dimensions
is measured in terms of number of
devices
okay so i will try to find a solution
for this problem uh and
the solution strategy would be given an
initial state
i will try to steer the system into some
nice states
from which i can find a periodic inputs
so there will be this prefix suffix type
constraints i know i am running out of
time but i will
try to quickly uh go over that
then if i can find some periodic
conditions then i can
guarantee my periodic inputs and
behaviors then i can guarantee
my constraints will hold
indefinitely so
and there's also you can do some
analysis on this system
uh to show when the systems are
steerable and that's related to
controllability in
linear systems that tells you uh
we came up with a special
controllability condition for this
uh this type of systems evolving on
integer grids
uh that tells us about some of the
fundamental limitations so this is a
reachability property
and you can figure out
when you can steer the histogram from an
initial state to an arbitrary final
state
just by looking at the cycles and
connectivity
of this graph and essentially
if all the connected components of this
graph has period one
and if you have a single connected
component then you can
achieve any modes of this histogram you
can achieve any distribution on the
histogram
okay so as i said there is a we want to
find this prefix suffix type solution so
that we can generate periodic
uh solutions in the end and to do that
uh what we will do is we will just look
at the cycles of this graph
because cycling uh through a
cycle in this graph corresponds to a
periodic uh
behavior of my system and
if you want to say certain systems are
in a cycle
that ends up being a linear constraint
as well so i can write down
everything with linear constraints and i
can write this
linear programming problem to solve
my original problem so you don't need to
worry about but all these constraints
all you need to know is they are all
linear constraints
the only thing is that these counts on
the histogram they are integers so if
you
impose integrality constraints this is a
mixed
this is an integer linear program and if
you relax those constraints
this is a regular linear program and the
important part is that this is
independent of the number
of systems and so we have some analysis
of this
thing if you are solving the integer
uh problem without relaxing to reals
[Music]
the solution is complete in the sense
that there exists
a prefix length and cycle length
uh for which this problem will be
feasible if and only if the original
problem is feasible
and for any ilp solution you can extract
the solution to the original problem
and from the lp solutions you can get
certificates for
non-existence and for the lp solutions
there is a nice finite uh cycle length
that you can consider
with which you can round the solutions
and
rounded solutions gives you a solution
for your
original problem so this is a bit
technical i will just
uh press on this and i will show you
some examples so
this is a typical duty cycle of a power
or or a thermostatic control load what
we are essentially doing is
we are changing this duty cycle
by our schedules and we are also
shifting them in time
so that they are not synchronized and we
can
achieve we can track arbitrary
uh power trajectories that are requested
by the grid grid operator so
i will quickly show something else so we
started with
discounting constraints and we said
okay maybe we can also think about
counting things over time instead of
having this
my counting things should be
invariant all over the time i can have
counts that are evolving over time and
we define
two different logics one is counting
temporal logic and
counting linear temporal logic and the
other one is counting linear temporal
logic plus
essentially this is like ltf but instead
of regular propositions now you have an
atomic proposition and number pair
and you interpret this thing
over collections of systems
uh and you can encode time evolution of
these constraints so
you can say things like eventually i
want at least five robots in a given
region
i never want more than two robots on
this bridge
and things like that and you can also
encode things related to
asynchrony so i will just wrap up
so uh we came up with this synthesis
technique that exploits symmetry and
fermentation invariants
it works across scales so it works for
tan systems or 10 000 systems
and in the limit this also has some
relations to mean field
uh games if you are familiar with that
and we are looking at applications in
different domains
um and we have this new logics as well
that we have some analysis for
and going back to the initial picture uh
we could change the scalability length
landscape
uh using these logics of course for a
limited class of uh problems
so i will stop there i think i will let
me also
give a big clap uh for everyone
thank you very much for the talk so
after some questions i think we can
probably take it most one questions
because we are a little bit running late
so so i have a question so uh
can you handle this way also collision
avoidance i mean you don't need to
i mean you can scale up collision
avoidance to like
thousands of uh we can handle collision
avoidance
uh as well it's a little trickier
but we have ways so you can encode
provision avoidance in
this logic which essentially says
at a given location uh there should
always be at most one
[Music]
but that's if you look at the
optimization problem that we are solving
and coding it in the semantics of the
logic or
encoding in the syntax of the formula is
not the most
efficient way uh since we are writing
down this
linear constraints there's a trivial
linear constraint that you can add
rather than writing it in your logic
formula and coding it
so there's a more trivial way of
collision avoidance but it's
captured in the uh logic as well if you
will
thank you thank you okay uh let me just
quickly
abuse uh my power as a chair uh so one
question is like in this new
logic with counting uh do you think that
you will be
able to apply all your previous
techniques or uh
so we can a plus
the things that we use this for
if you start with a graph
rather than continuous dynamics
everything
that we develop we can apply to this
logic
but then programs and stuff will work
with if you have counting maybe i missed
something
so we are dividing the state space
into regions and we are assigning atomic
propositions to those regions
and then we are essentially counting the
number of systems in
these different regions so we are
counting the number of systems that
satisfy a certain
atomic proposition at a given time so if
you can imagine
if you imagine this as an different
infinite trajectories at each time we
are
counting uh how many atomic probes how
many of
atomic proposition one is satisfied how
many of atomic proposition two is
satisfied
and so on and we are interpreting
this logic over that structure
okay i see and misunderstood something
initially so
thank you very much and uh let's sorry i
just want to make one observation so
so let's next yeah so we at some point
uh
you know quite long ago we had something
that was
superposition temporal logic linear
superposition temporal logic
linear super positional logic where we
had a sort of a state abstraction
and so we we actually we were not
counting we were computing densities
of formulas that are true so you know
so if you think of of this you know you
could say with densities that something
happens
lp relaxation in the limit goes to
densities
yes yes essentially there's a relation
with
density type mean field type approaches
as well but i will
i will check out your work yeah thanks
okay so please let me stop sharing and
we have our final speaker of today
that's uh
yasir yasser very are you sharing are
you not clicked accidentally
um i'm sharing now can you see my screen
yes so we will really have to i do
have to who is your chair am i or are
you
okay it looks that it's me so um
let me be uh it's really pleasure also
to introduce our uh speaker yasir shukri
who is now
as